well the wind's certainly kicking up all
kinds of pollen
and grass and many of you may have
reached for your allergy meds today
i spoke to a lung and allergy specialist
who realizes we are heading into the
heart of the season now it typically
starts in february
peaks in the spring and then it dies in
the summer and it'll pick back up again
in the fall
now the winds can certainly aggravate
those itchy eyes your runny nose
sneezing
but if you are a chronic allergy
sufferer and you just can't seem to get
the relief you need
it may be time to consider a blood or
skin allergy test
the more suffering you have from
a pattern of allergies then you go get
yourself tested rather than just
cycling medications taking this
medication for my it's not working
anymore i'm going to switch to this
so so rather than what we call
crisis management or symptom management
then we can offer more definitive
treatment options
might be worth considering chronic
allergies are often at the root of other
problems like asthma trouble
problem sleeping and headaches can all
sometimes come back
to allergies as well